hey I'm Karen boys from descendants and
you're watching Disney Channel
in fact now that's artwork 20 year old
Disney Channel star Cameron Boyce died
on Sunday after suffering a fatal
seizure in his sleep and his family is
morning on Wednesday Cameron's father
Victor took to Instagram to share this
photo and pay tribute to his late son
writing quote my son just hours before
he was snatched from our lives Victor
called Cameron's death the worst
possible situation and added quote I
hope that no one ever has to feel the
agony I'm feeling but no one is immune
to tragedy
Cameron was known for starring in
several Disney Channel projects
including Jessie I think we just got
discovered I knew I was good but I
didn't know I was sausage good his
co-star Debbie Ryan also posted a
touching message to Instagram praising
Cameron's many wonderful qualities she
wrote in part quote this ripped me up
I keep trying and I can't make anything
make sense the world was robbed were
better for you I'm Kenny until tomorrow
night tomorrow night I'll never make it
that is pathetic also part of the Jessie
family Skye Jackson who told thee T how
fondly she'll miss her on-screen brother
he was like a brother to me so it's very
sad and he was just a happy person so
it's very unfortunate but we're gonna
continue his legacy and I know he would
be proud of us so yeah to his ass
you